développer nos titres un point sur la
situation en ukraine dans l'est la
bataille du dombass joue toujours en
faveur de la russie la principale ligne
de front vous le savez c'est la ville de
severodonezk et sa région on prend tout
de suite la direction de kiev où se
trouve pour nous notre envoyé spécial
pauline godard bonjour pauline je le
disais la russie est en train
d'intensifier ses frappes sur l'est de
l'ukraine
oui le maire de severodonezk llc indiqué
que les russes contrôlées une très très
grande partie des zones résidentielles
de cette ville pour le moment il reste
encore seul un petit tiers de la ville
qui est aux mains des ukrainiens il a
ajouté qu'il y avait toujours des
combats de rues 24 heures sur 24 300
civils se trouvent toujours bloqués dans
l'usiné chimique d'azoté a indiqué la
vice première ministre ukrainienne à
l'expliquer pour le moment les
évacuations étaient impossibles baileys
elle a indiqué que si des couloirs
humanitaires devait être mise en place
cela devait se faire en coopération avec
des organisations internationales avec
les nations unies mais aussi avec des
membres de la croix rouge le gouverneur
de la région de lougansk à fait confirmé
hier la chute du village de metal kings
en périphérie sud de severodonetsk donc
les russes continuent toujours à avancer
la ville de l'iscid chance qui est la
soeur jumelle de cbre donne s est
également toujours bombardée même si
elle est toujours aux mains des
ukrainiens à l'est parle par le kiev
parle d'une augmentation des
bombardements sur la ligne de front dans
la région de donetsk notamment qui se
trouve juste à côté donc de la région de
lougansk voilà bonjour colline pour la
situation dans l'est ce n'est pas le
seul point de tension entre l'ukraine et
la russie dans le sud de l'ukraine aussi
au dessin et mikko live sont sous le feu
russe
wind violente explosion a retenti hier à
odessa selon le maire de la ville un
missile russe a été intercepté environ
80 fenêtres ont été soufflées par l'ong
de choc odessa est une ville que les
russes voudrait prendre puisque odessa
est une ville il y a un des plus grands
ports d'ukraine non loin de dessin vous
parliez de nicolay cette ville est
régulièrement bombardée aller sur le
chemin qui mène vers rodez saint nicolas
il se trouve également un côtier de la
région de gijon qui est actuellement
entre les mains des russes des millions
des millions de tonnes se trouve
actuellement bloqués dans les ports
d'odessa mais aussi dans les bords de
micola yves et ses millions de tonnes
bloqué provoque une crise alimentaire
notamment en afrique hier le président
zelensky le président de l'union de
l'union de là le président pardon
ukrainien s'est exprimé devant les
membres de l'union africaine il a
expliqué et déclaré que des négociations
difficiles étaient en cours pour tenter
de débloquer ces blocus sur au dessin
mais pour le moment rien n'est encore
fait il faut à falloir encore âprement
négocié pauline godard depuis kiev pour
france24 merci pauline et merci à
catherine dent reste rennes qui est avec
vous